[Music]
the day after uh president obama's
re-election last week uh one of our
writers dion cole did a piece he did a
sketch on our show
about how all the people in our very
very white office they all wanted to
congratulate dion on obama's victory
they followed him around everywhere and
it was it was funny it was a really
funny piece well since it aired the clip
has gone viral it's gotten very
popular but dion's been catching some
flack about it and right now he'd like
to come out and talk about the situation
address it directly please welcome our
pal dion cole
thank you
thanks conan well this there's this all
black website that i love to go to it's
called world star hip-hop there it is
and we did a skit that finally made it
on their site and they got over 500 000
hits i was very very happy until i read
some of the comments and not all of them
but some of the people were saying some
pretty harsh stuff about me take a look
playing the game is cold for selling out
there's no honor in that and i'm not
proud of this skit it's blackface
so sick of these sellout coons making
this race focus jokes on white shows all
it does is perpetuate the belief that
blacks are racist and obsessed with
playing the victim
old lionel richie looking mother
why would they say such mean things to
me
i really wanted to curse all of the
commenters out over at worldstar hip-hop
but i thought they might come after me
and try to shoot me or something
so instead i asked another writer here
on the show to come out right now and
read my response please welcome mr brian
kiley
thanks conan
first of all
who in the hell are you
to question my blackness
you don't know me i'm straight from the
hood
and if you keep talking crazy i'm gonna
get in that ass
just because you see me on tv with the
whitest dude in america
don't mean that i won't pop that thing
in your chest
and you're calling me a sellout because
i'm doing something positive by making
millions of people laugh at once
and word please
[Music]
and who are you calling a lionel witchy
mother
i'm sexier than lionel will ever be
women love my chocolate peanut butter
and caramel swirl complexion
and you've ever seen my stable of thick
fine ass
drop it like it's hot anywhere
brown and round
black and stacked
back you up into a wall and knock you
unkicked unconscious big ass booty women
you will never again question my
blackness
[Applause]
peace out y'all
[Applause]
by way
of brian kiley good work gentlemen